he supporters had demanded his freedom
since he was detained last year Luiz
Inacio Lula da Silva or simply Lula left
prison on Fridays surrounded by hundreds
of his supporters you have no idea of
the significance for me to be here with
you I who my whole life talked with the
Brazilian people never thought that
today I could be here talking with men
and woman who during the past five
hundred and eighty days we're here
saying good morning Lula good afternoon
Lula and yelling good night Lula no
matter if it were raining if it were 40
degrees or zero degrees on Thursday the
Supreme Court voted to reinterpret a law
that meant anyone convicted of a crime
was jailed after losing their first
appeal the ruling allows Lula and more
than four thousand others to exhaust all
their appeal options before being locked
up Lula was convicted last year of
taking bribes in exchange for public
works contracts it was part of the
so-called car wash corruption
investigation that saw dozens of
politicians and businessmen detained for
their role in cases that involved bribes
and kickbacks from Brazil's private and
state companies Lula da Silva left off
is saying that he's ready to fight
against what he says is the persecution
of the left under the presidency of Jo
balsan our it's not clear yet how he's
going to do that he wouldn't be able to
run for office right now because of what
is known here as the clean slate law
that bans politicians who have been
convicted for corruption
Lulla has always denied those charges
saying he was a victim of political
persecution the judge involved was
Sergio Moro who is now a also narrows
Minister of Justice his impartiality has
been questioned by Lula's Workers Party
the car wash corruption operation is the
largest in Brazil's history and
polarized society thousands demanded
justice on the streets because the
investigation discredited Brazil's
political class discontent paved the way
for the election of Giles who narrow as
president and that's why not everyone in
Brazil celebrated Lula's release on
Friday
I am extremely disappointed because
there is no reason and would a people
that can make a criminal he is a
criminal and a maker serious damage for
the country and there is right now
movement and congressman's that will
change the situation to allow the
provision in the sack races but in the
meantime Lula is free and instead of
being weakened by his time in prison
he seems determined to reclaim his place
in Brazilian politics once again
terasawa al Jazeera Sao Paulo